you need to prepare yourselves very
for a spin
[Music]
hey everybody the flashes back I love
the way that Cisco says that like he's
so excited and bears just like new phone
who dis he has no idea what's going on
like he comes out with the beard so it
just lets you know that he's been in the
speedforce
for a long time but because it exists
beyond space-time for him it's been
several lifetimes I think I posted a
video a while ago after Comic Con where
Grant Gustin was explaining that so
let's dive into this there's a couple
Easter eggs that you may have spotted in
a couple that you may have missed
there's a really important one it's a
nod to something that happened from
agents of shield in the Marvel verse 2
where Coulson came back from the dead
and he had this weird language in his
head that nobody could understand and it
turns out it was creer iding so when you
see Barry here with the Lightning eyes I
mean it just looks super badass like
he's that much more powerful full of
Speed Force but with the other hand he's
drawing on the blackboard all these
weird scientific symbols so I'll explain
that in a second but if you finding me
for the first time obviously I do all
kinds of flash videos all season long be
sure to subscribe to get it and make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the
videos I'll explain the giveaway stuff
at the end of the video too but there
will very literally be all kinds of
flash rings happening this season in the
TV show and on my videos so biggest
thing first the villain to the first
episode is the samurais you may remember
from the comics I talked about him in a
video earlier this season when we saw
him in the season 4 comic-con trailer so
that part isn't very new it's just the
timeline of events because we see Barry
come back the whole team comes to check
him out this seems like it happens
relatively early in the episode you look
in the back there - there's Caitlin that
looks like Caitlin there's no killer
frost to be found but we know in recent
episodes they've been filming that she's
full-blown killer frost again so I've
done a couple videos already explaining
about how she could go back and forth
between Caitlin and killer frost they
said that they'd be doing both of those
this year but beard Barry looks like he
just has no idea what's going on and
then just automatically starts going
crazy all over STAR Labs starts writing
down these weird symbols on the
blackboard they said that when he comes
out of the Speed Force he'll have all
this accumulated knowledge but won't
know
to make sense of it what does that sound
like if you've been watching any of my
Game of Thrones videos this season
that's exactly what happened to bran
Stark he has all this information
he's like the Internet and he needs
someone like Cisco to be the Google
search bar to help him search through
all that information that's inside of
his head so we might learn some crazy
new mythology about the Speed Force this
season it seems like that's what they're
implying because Grant Gustin said that
Barry's learned all these secrets but
doesn't understand them when he comes
out so the actual villain of the first
episode sounds like they take Irish he's
like hanging up in the air here
everyone's screaming that's what calls
Barry to action so in the comic book way
she's still his lightning rod sort of
like the thing that he always comes back
to remember in season two when he was
stuck in the Speed Force she's like
Barry come back to me it's kind of the
same thing she's like the one constant
in the multiverse they explained that in
pretty much every single universe of the
multiverse there'd always be an iris
that was with the Barry so that's like
the one thing that doesn't change even
if their personalities change a little
bit I can only read the top half of
Cisco's shirt here but I'm sure it's
another funny Easter Egg we'll see in
another trailer but he also says I have
a new suit for you do you want to take
it for a spin letting us know exactly
where that future flash costume comes
from meaning that the trend from back in
season 1 continues he gets a peek or
hears about something in the future and
then designs it so it's this big
causality loop so you can throw yourself
for a loop wondering what came first the
idea to make the future flash suit or
the future flash suit then he makes it
much earlier in the time period because
remember he went eight years into the
future during season 3 and that's when
we saw the costume so I think the whole
idea with that is that they stopped
being team flash after iris was killed
so it sounds like no matter what would
have happened they would have made this
future flash costume relatively soon
around this time so I don't think that
Cisco is breaking any laws of
time-travel or anything like that by
using knowledge from the future but that
aside now that we know sort of the
timeline of the episode we can probably
assume that this happens very early and
I'll say you know I'm not surprised that
Grant Gustin is big in the episode but
he did make it sound like he was only
show up at the end the speedforce this
time we're not going to necessarily see
Barry's experience in the sieve
speedforce we'll see kind of the effects
that the speedforce
has had on Barry and he's been in there
six months real time but the way I see
it as the Speed Force is kind of
nonlinear with time so Barry is
experienced kind of his entire life from
start to end infinity times over since
he's been in there so he's gonna have
kind of an awakening when he comes out
he's gonna be I think he's got some
knowledge that he probably doesn't even
quite understand yet he'll also be a
little scrambled he won't really be
himself the first time we see him so the
other big thing you may have spotted is
in the background you can still see his
old costume sitting where it's supposed
to be but we know that Wally wears it at
some point during the episode and
there's even a picture of him hanging
from the samurai katana and it looks
like the suit gets shredded in that
fight he says I'm looking for the flash
so it sounds like because Barry is out
of commission
Wally steps up puts Barry's old costume
back on and tries to trick the samurai
into thinking that it's him so it sounds
like that's how we go from old flash
costume to new flash costume is that
Wally gets his ass handed to him shreds
the costume it gets destroyed in the
fight and then there's no reason for
someone to wear that old costume after
that while he just goes back to his old
yellow costume but I know you're all
asking about flash rings the whole thing
about that is they confirm that they
would have the wedding during the
four-way cross over this year they
didn't say exactly which episode I'm
assuming it's going to be the Flash's
episode or it'll be the fourth night
like they'll have all this crazy
adventure then by the legends episode
which is still the anchor they'll have
the actual ceremony but you guys can let
me know they have the wedding during the
four-way crossover do they actually do
it during the final part of the
crossover or do they do it during the
flash episode because it's such a big
deal for the flash characters they tend
to save the biggest things for each of
the characters own shows so like the
arrow episode will focus more on the
arrow characters the Supergirl episode
will focus more on those characters you
get the idea but just to explain the
flash ring giveaway so like I've said in
previous videos I'm gonna try and remind
people how the giveaways work because
there's so many new people that have
come to my channel so all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber leave a
on this video if you win something I'll
put your name in the video so
congratulations to the latest flash ring
winner Jacob Nesbit
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
when I post a new DC video and there
might be an extended version of this
trailer that post tomorrow if there is
and it has new footage then I'll do a
new video but I'm also expecting an
arrow version of the trailer with
Deathstroke to post tomorrow too so I'll
do that video whenever it drops believe
all your flash video requests in the
comments below you can click here to
learn all about brand new Titans and you
can click here for brand new Rick and
Morty thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight